nouveau rassemblement anti pas chignon
sous haute tension ici un millier de
personnes présentes devant le parlement
encadrés par un important dispositif de
sécurité
un impressionnant dispositif de sécurité
on peut même dire à chaque coin de rue
ou presque
à travers la ville on a pu apercevoir
adea patrouille de police à savoir que
devant chaque bâtiment administratif
la sécurité a été renforcée et ici
autour du parlement
plus d'une dizaine de cars de policiers
a déployé afin d'assurer la sécurité à
du parlement à savoir qu'un sniper et
est même disposé à l'une des fenêtres du
bâtiment gouvernemental la raison la
présence de nicolas pashinian au sein du
parlement arménien il répondait
aujourd'hui aux questions des députés
concernant la crise politique que
traverse le pays
le premier ministre arménien a réitéré
sa demande de d'élections législatives
anticipées écoutez si l'opposition
parlementaire accepte notre proposition
nous aurons une opportunité d'organiser
des élections anticipées dans les délais
convenus cours en 2021
les élections sont un moyen de rétablir
la solidarité sociale
les autorités doivent être le garant des
élections justes et libres
j'envisage une réunion avec les
représentants et l'opposition
parlementaire
une demande restée pour l'heure sans
réponse de la part de l'opposition
parlementaire mais qui ne satisfait
toujours pas les nombreux manifestants
présents ici un depuis jeudi dernier
leur objectif est toujours le même le
départ de nikol pashinian considéré
comme un traître considéré comme un
paria depuis la défaite militaire est
dans le haut et karaba vécue comme une
véritable humilis humiliation nationale
pour la plupart des manifestants à
présent devant le parlement arménien
leur souhait un gouvernement de
transition jusqu'aux prochaines
élections l'an prochain et si élections
anticipées il doit y avoir elle devrait
à se faire sans la présence de nikol
pashinian écouté plusieurs partisans
anti un premier ministre arménien en
effet ce n'est pas une proposition du
premier ministre
c'est notre exigence qui nous a tous
réunis ici nous exigeons la démission du
premier ministre
nous exigeons de former un nouveau
gouvernement de transition et de tenir
des élections parlementaires anticipées
maintenant les autorités c'est de
changer de sujet et de faire comme si
elle souhaitait organiser des élections
alors que nous n'en voulons pas nous
disons mais si il faut absolument
organiser des élections dans le pays et
le peuple doit décider qui présidera le
gouvernement dans l'avenir je suis en
désaccord avec ce qui se produit chez
nous actuellement
le peuple est en désaccord on ne peut
pas agir comme ça on ne peut pas réunir
les gens pour les diriger contre leurs
compatriotes ce serait la guerre civile
j'estime que ce n'est pas juste
j'estime qu'en fin de compte les
élections auront lieu mais sans nicole
pashinian il n'y a pas d'autre solution
il doit partir et c'est tout
la manifestation s'est en tout cas
déroulée sans heurts une nouvelle fois
ici devant le parlement arménien malgré
les nombreuses provocations qui ont
émergé 1 sur les réseaux sociaux
d'où ce dispositif de sécurité beaucoup
plus conséquent que les précédentes
journées
à savoir que le président arménien a
reçu ce matin les leaders de
l'opposition pour éluder la question du
limogeage du chef d'état-major de
l'armée une demande souvenez vous faites
par le premier ministre refusé à deux
reprises par le président l'opposition a
demandé à armen sarkissian de porter l
affaire devant le conseil
constitutionnel afin de ne pas céder à
cette motion problème il ne peut pas
contourner la loi arménienne même en
saisissant ce conseil qui ne peut rien
faire
ainsi c'est inscrit dans la constitution
arménienne le chef de l'état se retrouve
donc face à une impasse et va devoir
accepter cette demande du premier
ministre arménien le chef d'état major
devrait donc a priori acquis t elle son
poste avant la fin de la semaine ce qui
devrait accentuer un peu plus la crise
politique que traverse le pays arménien